Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
« La perfection n’est pas de ce monde. »
« À l’impossible, nul n’est tenu. »
« Le mieux est l’ennemi du bien. »
Nous connaissons tous ces maximes,
et, pourtant, nous sommes encore nombreux
à continuer de chercher la perfection.
Lorsque j’enseignais à l’université,
j’ai régulièrement observé que certains
étudiants multipliaient les activités,
s’obstinaient dans des choix d’études
qui ne leur convenaient pas,
pour répondre aux attentes
de leurs parents,
qui souhaitaient les voir
embrasser la carrière idéale.
J’ai relevé à peu près le même phénomène
lorsque je me suis expatriée à Taïwan,
et que j’ai accompagné
des enfants à apprendre le français.
La plupart d’entre eux multipliait
à nouveau les activités extra-scolaires,
dans lesquelles ils devaient
sans cesse performer.
Ils étaient déjà exténués
par leur rythme de vie à sept ans.
Les recherches scientifiques
sur le perfectionnisme
m’ont confortée dans mes constats
et dans ce que j’ai moi-même pu
expérimenter en tant que perfectionniste.
J’ai donc envie de vous inviter
à réfléchir sur la notion
de perfectionnisme,
à vous en expliquer les effets,
à vous proposer des pistes
pour s’en détacher.
Et surtout, cela me donne l’occasion,
vous le verrez, de parler de moi,
car, avec mon perfectionnisme,
j’ai tendance à croire que tout
tourne autour de ma personne.
Pour commencer, j’aimerais savoir :
qui parmi vous se considère
comme perfectionniste ?
Pas besoin de chercher
dans tous les domaines -
merci pour ceux qui se sont manifestés -
pour être perfectionniste.
Nous le sommes tous un peu,
à certains moments.
Ce qui nous différencie
est la perception que nous en avons,
le sens que nous nous donnons,
le discours intérieur
que parfois nous nous racontons.
Le perfectionnisme
est la tendance, l’obsession,
à vouloir tout faire
avec un souci de la perfection.
C’est le désir irrationnel d’être parfait,
l’éternelle insatisfaction qui en découle
qui nous empêche à la fois de passer
à l’action et de nous réjouir de nos vies.
Certains d’entre vous pourraient y voir
une recherche de l’excellence.
Il s’agit plutôt pour moi
d’une recherche de l’inaccessible.
Être perfectionniste, c'est considérer
toute imperfection comme inacceptable.
C’est déployer des efforts
incessants au quotidien
pour maintenir un niveau d’exigence,
des standards très élevés,
voire, c’est là tout l’enjeu,
impossibles à atteindre
pour nous-même et pour les autres.
Ces 35 dernières années,
dans de nombreux pays,
le niveau de perfectionnisme
a considérablement augmenté
chez les étudiants.
Ils sont de plus en plus nombreux
à avoir de la pression
pour très bien réussir leur vie, ils sont
en compétition les uns avec les autres.
Ils ont des attentes
universitaires et professionnelles
de plus en plus irréalistes.
Peut-être vous l’avez remarqué,
de nombreux jeunes diplômés
écrivent sur leur CV « perfectionniste »,
comme si le perfectionnisme
était une caractéristique
qui augmenterait
leurs chances d’être embauchés.
Alors, bien sûr, on retrouve
chez les perfectionnistes
des qualités recherchées
par les employeurs :
fiabilité, rigueur, sens du détail.
Pourtant, étymologiquement
l’adjectif « parfait »,
dérivé du latin « perficere »,
renvoie initialement à l’idée d’une action
menée jusqu’au bout, totalement.
Or, l’un des problèmes
majeurs du perfectionnisme
est justement la difficulté
à finir une action,
à rendre une tâche dans un délai imparti.
Être perfectionniste, c’est prendre
et perdre beaucoup de temps.
C’est parfois passer des heures,
des jours, des semaines à peaufiner,
ou, à l’inverse, à procrastiner
par peur de mal faire, par peur d’échouer.
Si on applique la loi de Pareto, 80% du
travail est réalisé en 20% de temps,
on multiplie à peu près par cinq
le temps qu’un perfectionniste va passer
à essayer d’atteindre les 100%.
Et là, vous en conviendrez,
c’est tout de suite beaucoup moins
intéressant pour un employeur.
Le perfectionnisme serait même
l’une des causes de ce
qu’on appelle le présentéisme :
le fait pour un salarié
de ne pas être pleinement productif
à cause de son état physique ou mental,
alors qu’il est physiquement
présent sur son lieu de travail.
Puisqu’on parle de travail, vous avez
sûrement déjà essuyé des critiques
ou les foudres d’un collègue,
d’un manager perfectionniste,
qui était incapable de déléguer,
qui vérifie toutes les ponctuations.
Bref, qui n’était jamais satisfait
de son travail, ou du vôtre.
J'ai été cette personne.
D’aussi loin que je me rappelle,
j’ai toujours été perfectionniste,
autocritique, dans le contrôle,
pensant toujours
que j’aurais pu mieux faire,
je m’auto-sabotais.
J’étais incapable
de me réjouir de mes progrès,
de célébrer mes réussites.
J’avais une vision de la vie
assez binaire, disons-le,
tout était noir ou blanc,
réussite ou échec.
Seuls mes résultats comptaient.
J’ai refusé une proposition
d’intégrer Normale Sup,
car j’avais peur de ne pas
être à la hauteur.
J’ai longtemps été addict
aux « to do list » journalières
de quatre pages.
J'ai modifié des centaines de fois
les phrases de ma thèse.
J’ai été aussi incapable de recevoir
des amis chez moi à l’improviste,
de peur qu’ils ne découvrent
de la poussière en haut de mon armoire.
Ça va loin.
(Rit)
Aujourd'hui, je suis maman.
J’ai lu des centaines de livres
sur la parentalité.
J’ai testé le modèle
de la mère parfaite, évidemment,
et j’ai essuyé un burn-out
parental à l’autre bout du monde,
lorsque je vivais à Taïwan,
parce que j’étais persuadée
que l’univers entier scrutait
tous mes faits et gestes,
allait me juger au moindre faux pas.
Je ne m’autorisais aucune erreur.
Vraiment.
Heureusement, le tableau
que je vous dresse n’est pas si noir,
sinon je ne serais pas là.
J’ai eu un déclic,
grâce à mon fils de cinq ans.
Mon fils est drôle, curieux
et il est perfectionniste.
Les chiens ne font pas des chats.
Comme il adore les super-héros,
il a la méthode pour
se transformer facilement en Hulk.
Lorsqu’il colorie, il s’interdit
de dépasser les contours.
Lorsqu’il dessine,
il veut reproduire, trait pour trait,
et à la parfaite échelle, ses figurines.
Même s’il y arrive de mieux en mieux,
vous vous en doutez,
il a encore des difficultés à atteindre
le résultat exact qu’il s’est fixé.
Quand le personnage qu’il a dessiné
avec beaucoup d’application
n’est pas parfaitement
ressemblant à l’original,
il devient vert de rage.
Il écrase de toute ses forces son œuvre
et jette sa boulette de papier
à travers la pièce,
en criant : « C’est nul ! »
Quelle mère imparfaite je serais
si je le laissais faire.
Vous vous rendez compte
si les voisins l’entendaient,
que penseraient-ils de moi ?
Quel que soit notre âge,
être perfectionniste
n’a vraiment rien d’enviable.
Nous multiplions les vérifications,
nous consacrons notre énergie
à des détails que, la plupart du temps,
nous sommes les seuls à voir.
Nous nous auto-flagellons,
car nous considérons la moindre erreur
comme le drame de notre vie.
Cette quête permanente
et illusoire, j’insiste,
ne nous amène qu’à un seul résultat :
nous déconnecter de la réalité
et de notre bien-être.
Certains perfectionnistes vont si loin
qu’ils développent
un perfectionnisme pathologique :
épuisement, anxiété,
troubles alimentaires,
dépression, burn-out, pensées suicidaires.
La liste est longue.
On devrait pouvoir trouver
sur tous les bulletins
scolaires la mention :
« Attention !
Le perfectionnisme peut
gravement nuire à votre santé. »
Selon une étude canadienne
menée sur 450 adultes,
les personnes ayant des scores
de perfectionnisme élevés
ont quand même 51%
de risque de décès plus élevé.
Certains chercheurs
commencent donc logiquement
à envisager le perfectionnisme comme
un véritable problème de santé publique.
À UCLouvain, ils ont notamment montré
le coût émotionnel du perfectionnisme,
en réalisant plusieurs expériences sur
la manière dont les perfectionnistes
s’efforcent de gérer leur émotion
lorsqu’ils sont en situation d’échec.
Dans le test « match
two samples », par exemple,
les participants devaient déterminer
si une figure géométrique
était semblable à une autre,
présentée un peu avant.
A priori, rien de compliqué.
Pourtant, puisqu’ils pouvaient
revoir la figure initiale
autant de fois qu’ils le souhaitaient,
certains sont revenus
en arrière plus de 50 fois.
Dans des circonstances défavorables,
on comprend que non seulement
les perfectionnistes ressentent
des émotions inconfortables
plus intensément que les autres,
mais qu’ils recourent à des stratégies
inappropriées pour tenter de les réguler.
En fait, à partir d’un certain stade,
ils recherchent la perfection,
non plus par choix, mais par obligation,
parce qu’ils sont incapables de faire face
à un nouvel échec au plan émotionnel.
C’est pourquoi, à mon sens,
il est fondamental de comprendre,
de retenir, que l’erreur est humaine,
que le processus essai-erreur est
nécessaire pour apprendre, pour évoluer.
Que se passerait-il dans le développement
de l’humanité si, soudainement, les bébés,
par peur de ne pas voir approbation
et amour dans le regard de leurs parents,
s’arrêtaient d’apprendre
à marcher ou à parler.
Combien de découvertes scientifiques
et culinaires ont été faites par erreur ?
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais moi, je préfère finalement
me laisser guider par
mes envies, par ma créativité,
me tromper, recommencer,
plutôt que de ne rien faire du tout.
Mieux vaut fait que parfait.
Ces dernières années, dans ma vie
personnelle et professionnelle,
j’ai choisi la voie de l’optimalisme,
plutôt que celle du perfectionnisme.
Cela m’a permis de consacrer du temps à
des choses vraiment importantes pour moi,
à augmenter mon niveau d’énergie
et de confiance en moi.
Selon le professeur
en psychologie Tal Ben-Shahar,
les perfectionnistes,
les optimalistes, pardon,
sont des perfectionnistes positifs.
Ils ont une vision
raisonnable de la réussite,
ils considèrent les échecs
et les émotions inconfortables
comme faisant partie de la vie.
Et surtout, c’est ce qui m’intéresse,
ils osent se lancer dans de nouvelles
expériences au risque d’échouer.
Si vous ne l’avez pas encore compris,
vous êtes ma nouvelle expérience
optimaliste, cet après-midi.
J’ai l’impression que ça se passe
plutôt bien, je vous en remercie,
mais j’ai une confidence à vous faire.
Optimaliste ou non, le perfectionnisme
ne disparaît jamais complètement.
Nous apprenons à vivre avec.
Nous croyons souvent que nous en sommes
débarrassés, mais il refait surface.
Un peu comme le moustique
qui finit par nous piquer,
alors que nous nous
pensions hors d’atteinte.
C’est exactement ce qu’il s’est passé
cette nuit pour moi et les nuits d’avant.
Subitement, je me suis dit :
« Pourquoi me suis-je lancée
dans un TEDx ? »
« Je vais être la risée du public,
de mes proches, de mes clients,
du Président de la République. »
(Rires)
Ne riez pas, il suit avec attention
tout ce que je fais,
bien évidemment.
J’ai pris une profonde respiration
et je me suis rassurée
en me disant que, au pire du pire,
j’irais me cacher au fin fond
de la Patagonie pour élever des lamas,
et que je ne reviendrais jamais en France,
ou mieux, en Europe.
Alors, comment dépasser
cette peur d’échouer face aux autres ?
Sortir du perfectionnisme toxique ?
Comment accompagner quelqu’un
à être moins perfectionniste ?
Exactement comme
le processus en trois étapes
qui m’a conduite jusqu’à vous aujourd’hui.
Premièrement, observer
les situations récurrentes
dans lesquelles
notre perfectionnisme apparaît.
Accueillir nos émotions
et nos besoins associés.
En somme, développer
notre intelligence émotionnelle.
Savez-vous que seul 36% des personnes
savent reconnaître avec exactitude
des émotions qui les traversent ?
La deuxième étape consiste à imaginer
et se connecter à ce qui nous met en joie.
Vous avez vu, je m’illumine
quand je parle de joie,
à ce qui nous amuserait de faire vraiment,
comme si nous étions des enfants -
on ne le fait pas assez souvent -
pour enfin oser.
Oser faire ce qui
nous fait vraiment vibrer,
sans se soucier des résultats,
du « qu’en dira-t-on ».
Évidemment, cette mise
en action n’est pas facile.
Elle est même contre-intuitive, pour être
honnête, pour les perfectionnistes,
puisque nous sommes persuadés
que faire une erreur
détériore notre image, notre crédibilité,
et que nous allons être rejeté.
Pourtant, plus nous nous détachons
de l’image que nous voulons projeter,
et de celle que nous projetons
réellement à l’extérieur,
plus nous comprenons
que nous sommes responsables
de l’estime que nous nous portons,
et que nos proches sont prêts
à nous aimer tels que nous sommes.
C’est la magie, non pas de Noël,
même si c’est la période,
mais de l’amour inconditionnel
et de la vulnérabilité.
Alors j’ai une ultime
proposition à vous faire.
Et si nous arrêtions
de hisser la perfection
comme une norme, comme
un objectif de vie à atteindre ?
Et si nous développions
une société dans laquelle
les essais, l’apprentissage,
l’enthousiasme
sont valorisés ?
Une société dans laquelle
nous acceptons d’être des débutants.
la bienveillance et l’audace -
j’aime bien mélanger les deux -
sont érigées en principes de vie.
Et si le moment parfait pour oser
une vie imparfaite était maintenant ?
Pensez à ce que vous vous
interdisez par peur d’échouer,
à ce que cela pourrait
changer dans votre vie.
Que notre perfectionnisme
soit un trait de personnalité,
un comportement, une pathologie,
regardons-le différemment,
comme un signal d’alerte,
un ami, un moteur.
Nous sommes tous parfaitement imparfaits.
Et, si vous en doutiez encore,
rappelez-vous cet aphorisme
de Salvador Dalí :
« Ne craignez pas la perfection,
vous n’y parviendrez jamais. »
(Applaudissements)